yay okay
so if anyone's been here for a long time
you've heard Bulletproof by popularly
itself about four times
uh in that song it says is everybody
happy now is everybody happy
is everyone really happy
right so you must have had loads of
technical talks this isn't a technical
talk this is pretty much a fun talk uh
this is
a history of old ways of doing code that
I did when I should have I didn't know
better but I should have and I do now
that song's from the year 2000
so there may be someone who wasn't born
when that was released
um however it pretty much hits the
middle of all the demos I'm going to
give you so this is just to check you're
in the right room my worst code was my
best code
someone corrected me on Twitter and said
you should have had a better title it
should have been the best of code the
worst of code Charles Dickens so I
missed a trick on getting a very
literary title onto my presentation so
this is an example
of code
now this of old code now you may have
done retrospectives has anyone seen this
before
at the start of a retrospective how we
put this up
and we say whatever we find out whatever
we learn we were pretty much doing the
best job we could given what we had
given the technology we had and the
situation at hand you normally use that
in retrospectives
please apply this to the code or the
projects that I'm about to discuss
they were my worst code but at times
they were my best code
we're going to go back in time
this is where I scarily go
how many people were not born before
1993.
yep yep right this is code I wrote
before you were born
so okay
that's a scary thought
all right so all the calendars it's not
a day of the week of the month it's a
year
like you know
um I improvised
so one of the first things early I
worked on you may have seen Sky News
heard of bee Sky B
we wrote their first in-house weather
system I did it as part of the
independent company called Lighthouse
computer graphics
um
it was a long time ago
it was Windows 3.1
so if you wanted Graphics normally you'd
use max things like mac quadras were out
then and things like that but we were
using Windows PCS
so that was the kind of tool that the
weatherman would have
the weatherman when I delivered the
first system to train him on it
I handed him the mouse and he said
what's this
and I taught him what a mouse was right
were that long ago okay
so what that Windows 3.1 PC was going to
do was kind of produce some
basic artwork
it was then going to send it down a
Serial cable
because we hadn't got a network we
talked down serial cables to another PC
this PC
had a graphics card in it
graphics card I looked at what the price
of a what um inflation has done to the
price of that graphics card it was five
thousand pounds in 93 it now cost you
ten thousand pounds that is to do
broadcast video graphics
still
as in one image broadcast video graphics
not animations not playing back video
just the ability to show one image
that was inside there and what happened
was it's a little dos program
that took the rs232 set of commands and
could send them to an onboard processor
that churned through
those commands and actually rendered it
onto the hardware
they had a massive massive 1.4 Meg of
memory which is one picture in TV terms
of pal
and that would go out to the TV guys and
you'd have a weather map
and you go so how did this graphics card
take it did we create bitmaps did we no
no
we created a PostScript file
we sent a PostScript file down a Serial
cable and it took this PostScript file
that's designed for printers remember
that's what PostScript was really about
printers
and rendered it as raster graphics
we used coreldraw four point naught
indeed
um
this was
the windows equivalent of Adobe
Illustrator
in the same way that my cat is the
feline equivalent of I don't know mo
Farah running a gold medal it's not the
best thing in the world the one thing it
could do is produce an encapsulated
PostScript file
so how do you get a weatherman who
doesn't know what a mouse is remember
that to generate graphics on here that
we can then export to be a weather map
and believe me it looked like that with
little dots because it didn't have 224
million colors it only had 64 000 with a
limited palette right that's what we're
working with
so we need some kind of interface
for coreldraw
coreldraw is not extensible there is no
com components there is no scripting
engine so clearly what you need to do is
get the latest GUI tool in Windows that
is Visual Basic 1.0
right you know it's Visual Basic 1.0
because they still thought they were
equivalent to C in that they had a Mac
file a make file
what became a vbp in the long run
so we created one of these windows forms
apps with buttons on
the windows forms app could sit on top
of coreldraw hiding the bottom of the
window
on there we could put insert weather
symbol
put an arrow on all sorts of things like
that
and in order to get coreldraw to do that
we would send keystrokes to it
anyone who's done Visual Basic there was
a command called send keys and you could
send keys to another window
we would send alt f for the file menu I
for import and then import the right
symbol if they chose weather symbol
temperature 24 and it would locate the
right symbol on the disk and put it into
the Corral
not only that we did areas of hot sun
rain you know the kind of thing where
you see a blue area on a map showing
where the rain is
and we had we had rain we had Shadow we
had Sun we had blue for ice
they were all in the top left corner of
coreldraw little tiny boxes like one by
one pixels that you put in emails now to
track people
so that when we needed to export the Sun
we ran a macro
that clicked a mouse by the way Windows
could record Mouse movements and
keystrokes into something called macros
so you run this macro it would click on
the Little Dot that was for Sun
the weatherman would have said this
area's son it would group it with send
keys and then when you export it you
exported just the file to do the Sun
at the end of all this what you have
is a map like that
so we took
Windows 3.1 coreldor
we sent keys to it
we run Windows macros and we managed to
get this thing to do broadcast video
graphics at the time we did it for about
twenty thousand pounds all in as a
system for Sky the closest competitor
was 200 000 pounds
to deliver a system
but it was a bit clunky you know
I mean
we actually found
that when we tried to select something
in the coreldraw palette for another
tool to get a pointer or a joiner or a
circle
Windows macros couldn't click on them
for some reason
and it was the way the windows were
aligned
but we found if you used a utility
called Big desk that did a virtual
desktop for your entire windows
big desk somehow solved the problem of
window handles that allowed us to run
macros on it so it was a pile of
software all glued together
there was very much please do not mess
with the picture in coreldraw if you
delete the dots we don't have Sun
anymore
things like that
so it wasn't an easy ask and by the way
rendering that encapsulated PostScript
if you put an area of gray on like that
took something like a minute
this is not send it bang you've got an
image you used to see
that black would fill up
and then it would do a spray paint
nozzle for the whole of the outline like
this is a beautiful animation so we
never sent it live to Earth what they
did was do this capture it play out the
graphics that were captured
and that was my introduction to how to
create
a weather system I have the most crazy
components
we even then later did
um cloud and dig Cloud animations and we
used something called Autodesk animator
and this was a way of doing AVI files in
Windows in DOS actually in DOS we used a
language c c like scripting language and
we managed to get output of
actual clouds satellite images going
over but we were limited to 640 by 480
because that's the output of the card we
could get
so
that was an introduction to how how to
do things after vb1 days
sometime later
we've got much further on with VB and
I'd stop working for an independent
company and we now had a little division
inside this guy called broadcast
computing
we were part of the creative Services
Department there was an I.T department
they did desktops printing emails things
like that they did bringing a virus in
letting it because someone one of them
had admin it got onto every server in
the entire of the estate of sky and
everyone had to shut down for four days
while a group of Consultants cleaned out
all the viruses right let that be a
lesson if you're an admin don't map all
your drives to every yet server that you
have in the entire network
so we're on a different network we
didn't know what we were doing really
but we
've got a commission
they did a morning program oops
it's just full enough
Look At Me microphone failing
so they did a morning program to show
videos
um unbelievably
they called it Morning Glory if you
don't know why that's an odd title talk
to an English person and they can
explain it
and what this was was we were asked to
do the clock in the bottom left corner
and you can see this clock and it's a
kind of flower it started off Yellow by
the way and it's now going to Green
and it changes color so about every four
minutes it rotates through about five
six colors
and that was great so designer worked on
it here's the graphics
we got a yellow one we got a green one
we got a purple one we got a red one a
green one blue all the colors we needed
and we said oh you're not going to give
us
all the ones in between so that we can
just load them up and they said no can't
you do that because can you just take
these five six images and you do it
and we're VB programmers
and VB didn't have an image library
right there was no system.it bitmap and
things like that from.net
and it costs thousands to buy a library
in to do images
and we were looking at it going
well this is odd because we're gonna
have to deal with these as binary files
binary files are awkward in VB probably
vb4 whatever it was at that time
so it's quite hard to load and we're not
used to it because we don't really write
binary files that much so I tell you
what
these images are less than 64k that's
the maximum size of the string why don't
we load the images of string
why don't we then using a string
manipulate the data and save that string
back out and make another image
and that's precisely what we did
because it seemed to make sense and it
was easy
now you have to forgive
the resolution on this let's see if I
can zoom it
gonna refuse to do
[Music]
ah see if I can well let's go nope it's
not going to do it
can you read that just about
so one of the interesting things
in VB
not vb.net VB
there's a mid string operator or mid
operator
you can see the first one here
on this line
that line and what we say is get me the
caption off this button
and give me starting at character three
no zeros it's VB
they start at one and get me the next
four characters the really weird bit
about mid string is as well as getting
the middle of a string out
you could set the middle of a string
so it was an assignment operator I could
say middle of this string set it to this
I'm going to demo you this working on a
really simple label
by the way isn't this how every VB
program looked
all right there's a winforms app Greg so
if I do that you can see it hits that
line
the middle of that string
is the llo from Hello World
the moment I replace it
Bing just replaced it
and put a dash in it a high in it so
that's my proof to you that by the way
you can replace the middle of a string
and this is crucial
because you don't want to be fiddling
with strings by adding them together
because that takes a lot of time there's
a allocation of strings in the old days
it's really slow it's 16 bit it's
painful
so what we did was just load a bitmap
straight into
a string
and you did that I believe because I had
to write this code yesterday using a
file system object which is one of those
miraculous Chrome objects you can use
from VBA or VB
and I can load a string straight in from
a file notice we have no encoding we
don't care this is ASCII it's not 255
there are no other languages other than
English
all right
okay so we load it into that string fine
we can also save it
out from a string so we give it a string
we give it a file name we can save it
out
easy code
so what you can see I'm going to do is
we're going to load it
into a string
and then we're going to go through that
string backwards
and I go backwards because the data's at
the kind of end of the file so I'm going
to go towards the end of the file move
in a bit because there's an end of file
thing on a bitmap and I'm going to go
back three every is it three every time
yeah three every time because it's
arranged in red green blue red green
blue red green blue all the way through
the string naught 255 because this is a
24-bit bitmap
only with bitmaps there's also an end of
Rogue character which I've ignored in
this example because I couldn't
be bothered working out yesterday we
never had that in the original because
we use this weird format called TGA
which was before kind of it was a format
purely used for broadcast Graphics
almost by truvision
and what you get with this
is we will you can see what the image
looks like originally so if I looked at
this in hex it would be 0 0 f f zero
zero ff00ff all the way through the file
virtually to the end
so I go in 134 characters long I've
edited every third item set it to FF and
what we've done is change it from Blue
to cyan
I think that means I've added green and
blue together to make cyan
and then I've left I've only hit the
blue values that were already there and
now I've hit the blue and red next to
each other and we get magenta so I've
gone through that string poking in
values for RGB values
and then saved it back out
so our code that did this
oh by the way that's a Windows 2000 VM
that's having to run in safe mode
because I can't get the driver to work
properly in full size
and I didn't want to install with VB6 on
the modern machine
um because it's polluting in how it
installs I would have had to install the
jvm from Microsoft in order to install
VB6 that's how bad it would be
so what you get
is
we load in the yellow
we then load in the green and we take
two percent of what the yellow was 98 of
the green we had put that out in the new
file then we do four percent of the
yellow 96 of the green we worked all our
way through producing images like a flip
book for the entire animation and then
we just played them so that every two
seconds it loads a new graphic and
there's a new background which is a new
color
it worked perfectly because it's a
pre-render so you don't care about doing
it live you only have to do it once
and it was quick and you do it in about
two days because we've taken a pragmatic
View
we handed it over to the engineer
broadcast engineer looks at this
and they have like an oscilloscope to
check how all the colors look how all
the picture looks you've seen it in old
movies where they kind of have you know
whizzy things on old TV people trying to
work out uh what the picture looks like
he spent a day
and said there's a problem with it
it starts off yellow
and then it changes color so I keep
trying to adjust it to keep it yellow
but it doesn't work
and I said
oh did no one tell you how it's meant to
work and he nearly killed me
so
and that was June 95 so that's how we
manipulated bitmaps in strings in VB to
avoid having to do something difficult
with byte arrays
a few years later it's generally
election time
by the way we are still eight years
before YouTube exists
because of that reason and Sky News
didn't have a lot of viewers there is no
footage of the 1997 general election on
YouTube through his footage from the BBC
there was footage from ITV a big
commercial channel in the UK but none
from Sky News which is a shame
because it would be lovely to show you
this guy news general election a few
other Graphics unfortunately I can't I
just cannot get hold of them anyway
so I'm gonna have to explain how our
system works
now why did we have a problem we've done
local elections before so Regional
elections and things like that and
European
and we're a VB programmers we weren't in
the IT department we had an access MDB
file that's where our data was because
we're VB programmers and we use access
and access agrees with us on what true
and false are right because they are not
minus one and zero I assure you if
you're a VB or access programmer
and we stored them on a naval Network
3.12 file server this is basically
something that just gives you drive
letters and prints
that's it that's pretty much all it's
going to do
and during one of our local elections
one of the programs written by one of
our developers was locking the access
database file regularly
so such an extent we couldn't get new
results in
when we talked to him afterwards he said
my software worked perfectly though we
said no it didn't because it locked this
file and he goes no no my software
worked it's your software didn't
and you're like right
we had a few discussions like that and
then I thought that's not going to
happen again we've got to change how we
work
SQL server was version 6.5
it was still from a company called
cybase Microsoft hadn't Rewritten it
if the database got too big you had to
manually expand the files so that your
file server didn't run out of disk space
it was sensible
Oracle was a mysterious thing that the
IT department owned we had no idea about
it we didn't even know it existed
probably
so
what we thought was
and actually not we me what I thought
I think we should only allow data access
via a central location
right so there's one place you can get
the data
we will cache all the data in memory
every result every previous result every
name of a candidate absolutely
everything will all be in dictionaries
whatever arrays probably arrays probably
not dictionaries at that point
and we will save data to the access MDB
file
from this central location we will have
a lock on it so no one else can get to
it that will stop anyone else locking it
and we will do
call it a DB app somehow you'll connect
to this DB app with connections custom
and you'll use only remote automation
which was a forerunner dcom and they'll
connect to a winform application which
will hand out connections and give them
all the data from this miraculous cache
in memory
so what we actually did me not we was we
wrote Our Own database server just for
general elections that's what I did I
wrote effectively a very customized
database server
and how it actually worked was we had
this Novell server hosting an access MDB
file it's just a file system with a like
e Drive or F drive it talked to the DB
server which is running Windows nt4
when you run Windows nt4 workstation
Microsoft found actually with Windows
nt351 people were using it as a server
naughty naughty so they limit you to 10
connections
on a workstation which you can have many
more connections on a server so we had a
limit of 10 connections
we had a results processor coming in
from the news system
unbelievably what they did
was every time they got a new what
they're called wires so a result saying
hey there's a result for London East
labor have got this many votes
conservative got this many votes it
comes into The Newsroom system and their
Newsroom system prints it
to a serial printer only it's not a
serial printer it's us at the end of a
very very long cable rs-422 could go up
to 500 meters not a tiniest distance and
we would absorb effectively what was
designed to print out on an
old-fashioned printer and that's how we
got automated results we had two boxes
for manual results running nt4 result
viewers for the producers people in the
studio so they could look up any result
at the desk and find out what was
happening
we had an election analyst with Excel 97
who could connect to our DB app
DB server
and then
we had 2D Graphics that said hey Labor's
just won London East and a little
counter going how many seats each party
has run
and we had things like histograms so
labor vote 25 conservative 20. the
difference from last time maps of the
country with all the little colors all
over it you've seen them it's an
election
and then we even hooked into
a silicon Graphics workstation to do 3D
images of the houses of Parliament
really kind of
Doom style images of the houses of
Parliament almost where you had little
men that were colored kind of little men
appearing as it went along to show if
this goes like this there'll be this
many blue people on this side this many
red people and showing whether someone
had a majority
and that's how we run the general
election
not only that
every VB program that we ran was running
pause and continue
so that we could we did not run exes we
ran the full Visual Basic Visual Studio
so that if we had any logic errors in
our code
we could pause it edit the code live and
then press play to carry on running it
you may think that's a bit weird
but you only get to run this software
once that night never again
so it better work and the easiest way
making it work is pause and continue and
live edit
the other interesting thing that
happened that night
and you may go why isn't everything
going through the same router we didn't
know they weren't going through the same
router
we found out when the router at the top
that talked to our Network server
blew up
that Zone by the IT department
we stopped being able to write to our
MDB file
but unbelievably our magical DB server
had cached everything in memory and
could deliver all the results to all the
other pieces
so unbelievably it saved our backside
running it like that
I would never write that again
and think about this some of those boxes
are 32-bit
some of them are 16 bit Excel is
definitely 16 bit so Windows 95 had to
be 16-bit because of the the graphics
card we were using
so how did we do it that's a summary
the Visual Basic team were the guys who
brought you dcom I don't know if you
knew that but they wrote something
called oh maybe more automation they
designed it all it became decom that
maybe is why it's a bit dodgy right
we had to use Visual Basic 4 because we
needed 16 bit on Windows 95 but we
needed 30kbit on Windows nd4
XL worked we even connected it because
we had it on trial a deck Alpha NT
workstation could also absorb results
from our DB server
which may you may all go well yes
the different processor on a deck Alpha
to an Intel means it had to translate
every number and reverse it bit wise
because uh something called Little
Engine and big engine so it's quite
impressive it managed to do that
and the whole point was this software
only had to work once that meant pause
and continue and that meant we even
banned line continuation characters
because they broke pause and continue in
vb4 and you would have to restart the
app
by the way anytime you edited your code
you could not save it so everyone was
instructed did you edit the code you
select all copy into notepad and save it
down with the right file name so if you
have to restart the app you can patch it
all back in
and by the way everyone who worked on
this would start work at 10 o'clock on
Thursday morning
and we would finish at six o'clock on
Friday evening
so that was our shift pattern for doing
that election
it's a miracle anything got out
so
so that was the election which I can't
show you the graphics at all so annoying
if I may
I was
um a consultant
or no I was running my yes I was a
consultant so I'd stop running my I'd
left Sky I had gone to an interactive TV
starter I then started my own company
and then with a couple of friends and
then we broke that up and I just went
freelancing I got sick of writing
boilerplate code for doing access to
databases I was always writing something
that loaded it something that deleted it
something that inserted it something
that got a list of it it's really boring
I think what you'd like to do is
template all that
oh by the way if you haven't written RRM
try and write a compiler
but only do it once please just once
now here's the history of orms a brief
kind of Rundown
hibernate the Java library to do orms
object relational mapping we came out
about 2001.
and then
people in a.net world went
in front of it
because the X unit guys have already got
something called end unit so we should
do n hibernate so that was coming out in
2004.
Liam Wesley was ignorant of all of this
so I had no idea people were doing ROMs
I just knew I had a problem
um and I decided I was gonna create
something originally called easydb then
it became rapid DB and the idea was
I specify
a kind of generic database format I go
I'm going to kind of start with the
database and I'm going to Auto generate
code
and that specification would generate
all your classes for insert delete
update lists audit tables do primer keys
do foreign keys create the code modules
create the database Scripts make it in
SQL 2000 SQL 2005 access MDB IBM db2
MySQL Oracle so you can see I had you
know tiny ambition right oh and it could
also create it for SQL compact framework
for Windows mobile the old Windows
mobile that worked on a palm device
and create v b and c code to run on a
mobile device as well right I can tell
you now
there was no code generators
so we didn't have code generators no
nothing to help me write what the code
should be build it
we also had
no partial classes
either and no link so that's where we
were
and I spent ages writing this as just a
pet project because when you're a
consultant contractor you've got three
times so you're writing this kind of
stuff going this is really interesting I
quite like what we're doing you know how
to do it eventually QVC The Shopping
Channel came wrong and said can you
write us this system
for moderating SMS messages I know
you've written one before for Sky I had
to rewrite it and I rewrote it in two
weeks and I could only do that because I
could use my rapid DB library to say
that sort of database should look like
create me all the code modules then I've
got everything to write to the database
it is exactly what you would use now
I talked about it at the first ever
Community event developer developer
developer which has become DDD Melbourne
DDD perf all the ddds that were in the
UK
in 2005 by 2006 linked SQL had come out
I put rapid DB on sourceforge going
hey it's open source I don't care maybe
people would like it and support it not
one update by me or anyone else so no
one did
and that's probably because things like
linked SQL would smash it out the park
and then Entity framework killed off
link to SQL made everyone grumpy about
RMS in.net for a very long time because
it wasn't the best thing in the world
and eventually EF core came along and
did what linked SQL did and everyone was
happy again
that's my brief history of RRM
so what does this look like so this is
the code
taken exactly as is
from
sourceforge
it's yet another VB app it's gray it's
got gray buttons there's no styling
I'm gonna have to put glasses on because
it's tiny font and you know that VB
could never handle
anything like
um
zooming in or high res or any DPI
changes so it's awful that's why they
invented at WPF
so this is how you created your database
you've created a schema you did lots of
XML XML was the thing it was a thing
then not Jason XML was a thing I'd and
you could do all this and because I was
being so determined to be generic
you didn't get to say I want a 32-bit
integer you just got the chance to say
I think it's gonna be a type ID
I think it's gonna be a type short text
I think it's going to be a type number
and that's it that's what you got
and that made sure it would work across
every single database going in a generic
way
so you define this DB you said whether
it needed Keys whether it had primary
Keys everything like that
so this little demo which is straight
off sourceforge unbelievable that it
actually works I can load in a sample DB
it says yes I've loaded it okay
you can then create the core modules
code modules and it's created them so
let's go and have a look at those
there's someone down here
um
see temp
rapid DB
and we have code modules we have
electricity sharp code module
we can look at that in notepad plus plus
because it's a bit easier and you can
see how this is completely created oh
yes by the way I quite like regions
um so there's lots of region comments in
here but you end up with code that can
do things like search for a list of
companies
and that was your generic search and
then
you can see that further down it started
to do safe field names and things like
that
I don't think I knew about SQL
parameters so so I think I went and did
say field names to try and protect
myself against SQL injection here and
stuff like that
so all of this would boilerplate your
entire code base in c-sharp
or
C sharp for compact framework and for
both 1.1 and 2.0 because they were
different
and equally it could go off and create
your database for you
so if I create a new database
NDC Oslo new
there we are and I tell it to create it
in NDC Oslo new
you can see it's created all the tables
it's even got things like foreign keys
there so you've got foreign Keys going
between the order info product info
table so you can see how many items and
products have been ordered all that kind
of thing all the nice relational
database stuff and they even handled
things like auditing so audit tables
the reason you shouldn't write that is
it's way too ambitious so it didn't
really do transactions as well as it
should have done
it never could adopt a linked SQL
because we had no partial classes once
you generated the code modules and then
you started hacking them
you were bust because you couldn't
regenerate them right because your
changes were now thrown away so if we'd
have had parcel classes whoa my head
would have gone bam because I could just
add stuff and then I could do my custom
stuff and it would have worked really
nicely but I'd have failed to do the
linked SQL so I let ages later Mark
Rendell went and sorted out simple data
doing much nicer way of doing things and
even he gave up on it because you know
the effort's not worth it
but the interesting thing about that is
it allowed me to generate a demo for QVC
UK in under two weeks that got me the
contract for the next seven years at 600
pounds a month to run the system at QVC
that bankrolled my entire contract
company for the next six seven years
so it's also taught me a hell of a lot
about databases it taught me that if you
were in IBM db2 your database name
cannot be longer than eight letters
right because then it can be exist on
any file system that db2 may run on
including mainframes where you are
limited to file lengths of eight letters
um it taught me that Oracle needed to
prefetch IDs it doesn't have Auto
incrementing primary keys so you have to
prefetch the ID the code handled that
Oracle if you save a null a empty string
to a string column it coerces it to null
in the default options so you have to
handle string manipulation properly so
it taught me huge amounts of our
database and it got me a contract that
kept my company going for six years
it didn't get support and I didn't
really continue using it
by March 09
I was still an independent
and I delivered a ticketing system to a
company called electric Productions they
do programs have I got news for you the
queen was at number 42 a load of Comedy
programs on on TV in the UK
and they wanted something to handle
giving tickets for free to their
television recordings managing the
system and things like that we'd written
one previously with another company but
they wanted a rewrite of it so they
could do electronic ticketing if they
could do electronic ticketing where it
just sent them emails
that would save them 10 000 pounds a
year in mail-out costs and printing
costs of sending tickets out therefore I
had ten thousand pounds
given to me to write a ticketing system
and it would save money within one year
so that's good
this was a classic ASP application
so
it was interesting to note that when I
got my code base for the ticketing
system out
though I tried to load it in Visual
Studio 2019
it converted it really well and then
told me you can't possibly talk to that
website because I forgot you've got to
run Visual Studio in your Administration
mode to talk to is
we're just going to run it so
and then you get to weird stuff like
so what is the administrator login
because I can't remember what it would
be
so here's something
you could either say this is my best
code or my worst code depends how you
feel about this
I immediately went into the user info
table
that's where my logins were I looked at
it and said
there's a hash in assault I've done this
properly I didn't put a bloody plain
text password in so I can't get to that
okay so how do I deal with that
tell you what why don't I just delete
everything from that table
so I'm just going to delete that
hey
there are now no users in this system
to log in with which is great because
what it says is give me an initial login
name that I'll make administrator
nice
and you know what I thought at that
point you're a genius
and I can't retype a password live
let's do that
and I've created my first login and the
nice thing is even though obviously
it's the first login I can still access
everything that was in the system right
that call it security by the way I also
couldn't remember the Windows 2000 VM
admin password very similarly in Windows
2000 if you go in and delete one file
called Sam that's somewhere in Windows
system 32 Etc something something
something you can Google it if you
delete Sam the one file that's the
entire password database for Windows
2000 and when you start it administrator
starts with no password
all right
uh someone named Microsoft thought about
security and then decided not to do it
so
this is the main screen for the ticking
application this is classic asp
oh I think it's a no it's ASP web forms
um you would be able to tell it's ASP
web forms because there will be
something called view state in it that's
massive
this hidden field right
and when I first did this I thought
right this is a list of all the tickets
people have requested
and we are going to have tickets that
are pending and we're gradually going to
reject or accept them that's pretty much
it and we might adjust how many tickets
they get as well because they asked for
four but there's so many people asked
for them we're only going to give people
two and things like that
and I tested it out and we had you know
10 requests in and I did this post back
then it came back rebuilt the three
tables you did reject went in did the
work on rejecting a ticket came back
rendered the tables it was fine
we then had tested it with how many
ticket requests you will get 500 every
time you hit a button it took 20 seconds
because they had to go back tell it by
the way this one one thing here is going
to get rejected I would save that in the
database and then come all the way back
and re-render the screen
if there's 400 requests and it takes 20
seconds to do a page postback
that is 130 minutes that's two hours to
a job that should take about 10 minutes
right
not going to work
the really interesting bit is someone's
going to go Ajax nope nope nope the new
thing was jQuery
right I had jQuery at my side
so what could I do with jQuery to make
this work
well let's go and have a look at the
code
and this I can make bigger which is
really good
there we are
so
by the way for anyone who's going oh wow
that's a VB programmer writing
JavaScript he's put M's in front of
things to make sure that I understand
it's a module level variable
um which is generally what I just did
so
we have things
so what I'm looking for is a rejected
reject ticket
so what the reject ticket button
actually does is it says move this table
row
this table row Name ID so there's an ID
for each table row
and move it to this other table
and then update a ticket request thing
if we go and look at what move table row
does it's a bit of jQuery that goes and
does a bit of funky stuff
so that when you hit the re reject
button
or pending button so I'll hit pending
look at that
whoo
so this is just moving things between
the tables
so maybe super fast
it has yet to save anything
this is crucial you have not saved what
you've done so far
the more amazing thing is a browser when
told that this row belongs over here
just renders it instantly
right just does what it's told is this
row was over here but it's now over here
that's fine who cares
if you view the page Source you would
end up finding a hidden field
not view state
not one of the normal ones
but ticket request updates
now the tricky bit is what I actually
need
is to look at it live
because I want to see what values in
there
[Music]
in the body
well it's fine fine fine
and there you are
so what value
and I've gone past it that's naughty
ticket request updates
it's got values look can you see them
the t means it's a ticket
the number is the ID
and the equal is what happened to it
zero means it's been moved to pending
minus what means rejected
plus what means accepted in fact I think
the numbers refer to the number of
tickets you've requested as well
so what you do in this screen
is you can fiddle endlessly going
reject
pending reject pending to the same
person they keep getting added to this
hidden field that when you finally hit
save and it does the massive web forms
postback we take the hidden field
and we process it ignoring any
duplicates
we have created an event stream
architecture in a web form
that takes an event screen stream of
whatever the customer did and only takes
the most recent update as valid
so this is amazing
you know
to be honest this is completely insane
and how I got away with it I don't know
how I even came up with this I can only
believe that I was powered by some form
of alcohol at the time
and it was jQuery I could put jQuery on
my CV
in a way that you should never put
jQuery on your CV
and then from our last example
it's September of 10. 2010. I was doing
m33 pile file processing at a startup
so this is Warner Music Emi and Sony
giving us their entire music collections
what the entire music collection of Emi
means is you get delivered on a pallet
buy a forklift truck
a set of hard drives too heavy for a
human being to carry do you then have to
plug into your server copy all the files
onto your servers onto your San and then
start processing them they are all
uncompressed files each of these is like
400 Meg it's that's right because 650
Meg was a CD
it was a bit more compressed it was
lossless compression in order to get
under the 650 but it was big there's
lots of 20 30 40 hard drives that you
plugged in
the initial developers were trying to
process it using biztalk
like this is insane they were moving 600
Megs at a time through Biz talk server
and it seemed to take quite a while
they then were talking about how can we
Market as process so do we do this
and I went
I think what we might do
is we'll use our sand storage 100
terabytes of sand storage in the
cupboard
um connected just map disk drive letters
to machines
and what we'll do is we'll load an album
say album one eight seven six seven six
and we'll put it in a receive folder and
there'll be little jobs waiting for
folders to get filled but wait till that
folder seems to be not busy for at least
five minutes that there's nothing added
to it once there's nothing added to it
again
it'll look at it look at the XML the
metadata check all the files have
arrived if they haven't move the folder
not copies moves the entire folder to an
error folder
if it succeeds
oh yeah and it fills in the details of
why it had an error
if the artwork fails so artwork
processing we've made thumbnails we made
big ones we made ones for website ones
for the front pages website one for the
middle all that kind of artwork thing we
did that as well
unbelievably Warner used to send us
images that would fail in the.net
framework
but would work wouldn't load in
paint.net either because paint.net is
built on.net framework but we're loading
Ms paint which you could then re-save
and then use as your master you would
find that in the details
and you also then did a transcoding job
that was the longest thing that happened
and because it's just a file on a file
system we could Farm it out to loads of
little workers that could do individual
files so they'd all go in and go right
have we got any files to do this right
I'll grab that file I'll start
transcoding it
the way you transcoded the entire
catalog of Emi and Warner in our office
was everyone when they left for work in
the evening
set a little executable going
it's just you can
so a little executable going on their
machine which would go off and start
processing messages
and then in the morning they'd close it
down because they'd want to do their
actual job right so it's one of those
things so that was our rendering Farm
everyone's desktop PCS in the evenings
don't turn them off please
any problems with transcoding it would
put them over in the error
and it would just move these folders so
this folder got moved from received to
artwork to transcoding to complete if it
had any errors it got moved to errors
we found out that if you use UNC paths
you know how you go slash slash my
server slash foldershare and if you move
that to exactly the same kind of UNC it
did a copy then a delete
but if you map the drive letter it went
like that
it's instant because it writes to the
file system and goes I can just edit a
directory entry and move where it exists
on the whole system
so I did all this and we when when you
have a problem with it you look in the
text file you find out what's wrong you
go and edit it and then you how do you
resubmit
well you examine the error details
handed it stuff rename files that might
have failed by the way a question mark
that exists in OS X do you know you can
have a question mark in a file name on a
Mac
do you know that that question mark
isn't the ASCII question mark character
it's an extended code question mark so
it will not be found if you match a
title and your metadata to the file on
the file system because it will have
renamed it so we had to deal with all
that
so we fix things and all we did was
rename error details.txt so we had an
audit of what happened
move the file back and then the process
would start again it would just go back
so we had the ability to replay any
encoding and someone said
how come
we've spent two years trying to work out
how to get this through Biz talk and how
to do fancy kind of encoding system
and this is how it works and my answer
was
you don't get to put I wrote something
that moved files onto your cdb
right it's not a sellable skill
and that the last example I've got
because by now I then moved to huddle I
had people like Ian Cooper and Toby
Henderson working I was working with and
they wouldn't allow me to do like
this
right let's be honest we grew up we had
better tooling we did better things
but in all those that history of stuff
it allowed us to get work done get stuff
out you will at some point in your
career even now be asked to do stuff
like this it is not a problem
as long as you understand what you're
doing and it solves the problem for the
customer
and then possibly you either leave the
company
or you fix it and do it properly
so that's why I believe some of my worst
code was my best code and I hope you
enjoyed a more fun talk so you didn't
have to think for about now thank you
very much
any questions I you might have some very
weird ones but I'm happy to answer any
no
enjoy the rest of the conference and
I'll be on the cruise and I'll be at the
party you will notice me at the party
that's all I can say
so see you tomorrow or tonight
thank you very much